so here are some more celebrities who
changed their name before getting famous
Blake Li's real name is Blake Brown and
Gigi hadid's real name is jelina Bri
larsson's actual name is Brienne sedoni
dlers she changed her last name to lson
because she was tired of people
mispronouncing her French last name and
she got the name Larsson from the
American Girl doll Kirsten Larson which
is her favorite American Girl doll Lucy
hail's name is actually Karen hail okay
this one really threw me off Travis
Scott's real name is jacqu Burman
Webster II ski ol is actually Brian Ray
trout when he was a kid his little leag
coach gave him the nickname sker and ol
is his first stepfather's name who be
Goldberg's real name is Karen Elaine
Johnson so she took the last name
Goldberg from a Jewish family member and
she decided to go with the name whoopy
like a whoopy cushion because she's
always gassy and I am being de serious